ladies and gentlemen president zielenski
dear vladimir
thank you very much for the opportunity
to contribute
to your very important discussions
we see every day with admiration how the
brave citizens of ukraine have rallied
together
to support and defend their homes
and those of their neighbors in face of
russia's brutal invasion
you are an inspiration for so many
around the world
and we are with you in spirit and with
concrete support
soon the time will come for ukraine's
reconstruction it is actually already
starting now in the liberated areas
around keefe and elsewhere
ukrainians are coming back to their
devastated towns and villages to remove
the debris rebuild houses and
infrastructure and restart the economy
this is an enormous effort
and we need to mobilize all our
available resources to rebuild ukraine
and therefore i wholeheartedly support
president zelinski's proposal
to involve through partnerships
the cities and regions of the european
union in these reconstruction efforts
europe's strength is based on our
citizens working tirelessly
on improving their daily lives and the
future of our children in cities towns
villages neighborhoods
our cities and regions have experience
and expertise
when it comes to rebuilding and managing
the daily lives of citizens
and we want to share this expertise with
you we want to work together with you
peer-to-peer cooperation
at all local and regional levels
will allow us
to speed up ukraine's reconstruction
just think of
architects companies bankers
experts
from the european union and ukraine
all working together
we will expand exponentially the number
of twin cities and twin regions between
our two peoples
you can count on the huge solidarity of
european citizens in support of ukraine
and i know
that we can also count on the european
committee of the regions
that is actively linking our local and
regional networks in the european union
with their ukraine counterparts
the entire european union stands behind
ukraine now
and after you have prevailed and
overcome this horrible war
we will help you to reconstruct your
country
and we will work together with you on
your european path
thank you very much for having me